smithsonian museums yeah
try saying that fast in the nation's
capital or reopening to visitors today
now they've been closed for more than
six months because of the pandemic
chip reid got an exclusive look at what
the national museum of african american
history and culture is doing
to keep visitors safe chip good morning
to you it's so glad i'm so glad to see
that they're opening up this is long
overdue people are ready to go but why
was it
so important to reopen this museum now
well gail you know the central mission
of this museum is to teach
people about the long struggle for
racial justice in this country and
people who work here say
that is a lesson that might well be more
important right now
in this country than ever
where crowds used to gather outside the
national museum of african-american
history and culture
staff members are now preparing for a
new reality
of course you have to wear a mask museum
acting director spencer crew says for
the first couple weeks there will be
just 250 tickets issued each day
compared to over 4 thousand before the
pandemic
video exhibits and touch screens will be
turned off and the lobby is now equipped
with plexiglas
and hand sanitizer we're really trying
to make sure this the public is safe but
also our staff is safe
i understand you have sensors that can
keep track of the numbers of people
coming through
we do they're high up in the ceiling and
we can just see how many people are in
each space
so as it gets too crowded we might want
to direct people to other parts of the
museum
three other smithsonian museums also
reopened today with similar precautions
after months of nationwide protests
calling for racial justice
cruz says these exhibits offer a timely
message
we've always been a place that's looked
at social justice and uh i think as
people come to visit us they will see
that history
they will understand how people have
really worked very hard to try to make a
difference in the world
and hopefully it'll inspire them to also
try to make a difference in the world as
well
the museum has been collecting signs and
other artifacts from recent protests
gathering stories from people marching
in the streets
and from those impacted by the
coronavirus pandemic
which has seen blacks hospitalized at
nearly five
times the rate of whites one of the
things that we're trying to do is to
capture how all this is impacting
individuals in
our society and as a consequence we've
created a space where you can talk about
how covets
affected your life and what kinds of
things you might be doing to try to
have it lessen that impact would it be
fair to say that in some ways this
museum is needed now more than ever
yes absolutely we want to make sure we
tell the unvarnished truth is what we
often say
but also to point out that even in the
struggles that people face
there are upsides to it we want our
visitors to see both those things so
they understand that
there'll be challenges but there are
ways of confronting those challenges and
maybe finding a better path to follow in
the future
and spencer cruz says the response to
the reopening has been
overwhelming there's already a long
waiting list to get in
as i mentioned they're going to start
about 250 people today
gradually work their way up to 1100
people over the next
two or three weeks but that's only about
a quarter of the size of the crowd they
used to get before the pandemic but it's
just not safe to let those kinds of
numbers in
now gail yeah but just the fact that you
can go
back again it's great thank you chip you
remember back in the day we got to take
the show there we got to
broadcast there live we were the first
first network to be able to do so
it's such a powerful powerful powerful
place the the exhibitions that they have
on display you just walk out of there i
don't care what color you are
you can't help by be moved by the nation
and what we've been through and what
we've done and what we've accomplished
i'm so glad museums are reopening
sort of gravity all over the i went to
the museum of modern art this week
again very small very small group of
people in there but it was just
it was just so nice to be able to go at
all yeah and so i'm really glad to see
these
but 250 people that's a big difference
from 450
000. yeah it's worth it i think there's
going to be lines be sure you're
socially distant in the line
well they have that too it's worth it it
is definitely worth it